aujourd'hui on est réuni pour parler
d'un tout nouveau produire tout nouveau
il sortit ya peu de temps en tout cas ne
vous ai pas encore passé celui là c'est
le swift 5 swift 5,2 acer et j'aime bien
ce typologie de francs 10 parce qu'on
est vraiment dans l'idée de
l'ultraportable du compact du facile du
léger du transportable partout on veut
sympa j'aime bien l'idée pas là vous
avez compris un peu l'histoire
aujourd'hui on va donc sans regarder ça
on va diviser la vidéo en deux parties
première partie c'est une découverte
j'ai voulu être un peu naïf c'est ma
première rencontre avec ce produit donc
je vais prendre le temps de le regarder
on va découvrir ensemble les
connectiques l'écran un peu à quoi il
ressemble pourra vraiment un sentiment
brut un sentiment sans aucune cotisation
sur ce produit
et puis d'ici quelques jours laissez moi
un petit peu de temps et bien je vous
ferai en retour beaucoup plus complet
pour vous dire ce que j'en ai pensé
après plusieurs jours et comme ça vous
aurez tout vous saurez tout et ça ça
s'est super bien
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec sofia sauf
sharks est un vpn qui vient protéger vos
connexions internet
ils viennent notamment éviter la
fluctuation des prix d'achats sur
internet que ce soit pour réserver un
hôtel un billet d'avion il vous protège
notamment lorsque vous connecter en wifi
public celui d'un hôtel ou encore d'un
restaurant en cryptant et en sécurisant
vos données et vous permet également
d'accéder à vos sites web préférés qui
sont bloqués par un g au blocage je
pense notamment à netflix us si vous
êtes en france à netflix france si vous
êtes aux us et ça vaut également pour
mike annales si vous êtes à l'étranger
avec un seul abonnement
vous pouvez vous connecter sur un nombre
limité d'appareils en même temps vous
pouvez utiliser sans sharks sur pc mac
et ios android
une smart tv apple tv chrome firefox
xbox ou encore playstation vous
bénéficiez d'une assistance 24h sur 24 7
jours sur 7 et vous êtes satisfait ou
remboursé dans les 30 jours qui suivent
votre souscription et surtout se
recharge ne concerne absolument aucune
de vos données
vous bénéficiez également deux soeurs
sharks a l'air qui va dire vous alerter
lorsque vos données ont fuité sur
internet
vous pourrez ainsi modifier vos mots de
passe pour venir sécuriser vos comptes
avec sur chaque vous pouvez vous
connecter sur internet sans publicité ni
traceur je vous invite donc à venir
découvrir et essayer sans char que
travers des liens en badra description
vous bénéficiez de 83 % de remise et de
3 mois offerts et ça c'est vachement
bien
premier truc mocky qui m'interpelle un
petit peu c'est un peu flexible
ça bouge un peu alors après est-ce que
ça va poser problème par la suite je
pense pas on va commencer tout de suite
par les connectiques comme ça me sauve
et ouvre on a ici une prise d'irak ça
c'est sympa on a deux usb
de l'autre côté ici je vais avoir à ma
charge
j'ai du hdmi de l'usb de l'usbc sur le
dessous pied donc des grilles pour la
ventilation je dois avoir mes hauts
parleurs à mon avis qu'il avait situé
sur le côté à l'avant du produit
qu'est-ce que je retrouve et bien
globalement pas grand-chose de quoi elle
ouvrit rouquet puis on a fait le tour à
6k ça c'est marrant vous le voyez
chrissie swift juste là ok bon c'est les
petites finitions c'est assez sympa
quand je louvre qu'est ce que je vois du
fait qu'ils viennent se lever comme ça
la voyez ça ça vient de repousser ce qui
fait qu'en fait ça voulait laisser
permet de dissiper la chaleur donc ça
permettra de gagner un peu en
performance l'aménagement est plutôt
bien au niveau du clavier ça c'est un
truc que j'apprécie j'ai un peu la même
sensation
bouge un peu en fait ici j'ai vraiment
chipoter c'est du point de finition le
trackpad est plutôt bien 200 en tout cas
à tracer fonctionnel capteur
d'empreintes digitales ici pour venir
déverrouiller hockey un point connaître
ici certes ordinateur c'est que vous
avez un seau qui est quand même médium
médias mais guillon n'a pas beaucoup de
base vont à des petits haut parleurs
mais le spectre est pas complètement
décalé il vous fait écouter vous allez
voir complications entre le cos allaient
gérer ça que je pense que ça donne envie
de rentrer mais parce que j'ai aussi
déjà château s'ils en font la spa
l'emballement rôle qu'il n'ya pas très
très gros volumes après ça suffira un
vraiment à venir travailler pour venir
collaborer pour d'avoir des amis qui
vous échangez que regarder un film
le vous avez un seau 10 km à ces médiums
n'a pas un spectre très large
si vous voulez aller plus rose que le
préfet saisira brancher un casque
directement avec la prise jack ou alors
pourquoi pas oublier tous le deuxième
point vous n'avez pas la rue et la
luminosité de tout ça fait c'est pas un
écran qui est très très très vidéo donc
si vous voulez travailler à l'extérieur
etc un peu le soleil est bien il ya un
moment où vous risquez plus de s'offrir
voyez là je suis baissier et là je monte
au max voilà je suis pas très évident
que ça c'est aussi un un des points à
connaître ici moi ce que je vais le
strait premières découvertes une fois qu
c'est l'idée de l'ultraportable et
connectique me paraissent assez fournie
est ce qu'aujourd'hui au lieu de mettre
voiliers de de l'usb a de chaque côté
est ce que j'aurai pas mis nu sbc de
chaque côté ça c'est vraiment la
question que je me pose aujourd'hui les
smartphones et les différents
accessoires viennent se branchait pour
la plupart en usb c'est un usb c'est
d'un côté de l'autre ne paraîtrait plus
intéressant que je vais apprécier c'est
le fait d'avoir du hdmi donc si je veux
bien branché ici un moniteur et bien je
peux le faire j'aime bien l'idée d'avoir
aussi mal apprise d'axa me paraît aller
dans le sens de l'histoire donc déjà
pour cette première découverte tout de
suite ça en tout cas ça me convient bien
votre bébé maintenant vous me dire ce
que vous en pensez vous et puis on va se
passer quelques temps pour vous ça va
être très rap et le temps d'un
claquement de doigts pour moi quelques
jours le temps de l'apprivoiser un peu
plus on y va swift que 5,2 acer on est
vraiment sur l'ultra portable c'est
vraiment l'idée cet ordinateur l'aïe
si vous êtes un gamer c'est pas une
machine qui est fait pour vous vraiment
pas si par contre vole une solution
facile à transporter très légère à peine
plus de 1 kg vous pouvez emmener très
facilement avec vous glisser dans un sac
et se fait complètement
oubliée eh bien je pense que cette
machine là pourrait vraiment est fait
pour vous et pourrait vraiment bien vous
intéresser
c'est vraiment ce qu'on va chercher ici
un moins de 15 mm d'épaisseur un ratio
core écran de 90% un petit châssis qui
en magnésium et lithium et magnésium
aluminium
je viens des baissiers l'écran tactile
14 pouces petit écran c'est une dalle il
ps on a un écran full hd 1920 par 1080
c'est du 16/9 à ces anneaux annonce une
luminosité de 340 knicks qui va pas être
extraordinaire si vous allez en plein
soleil pour travailler pour de grandes
sessions de productivité mais pour
l'intérieur et si vous n'avez pas le
soleil qui tape en direct au dessus vous
n'aurez pas de problème ça fonctionnera
une gamme colorimétrique 100% srg béton
n'est pas sur une machine qu'est dédié
ici pour les créatifs vraiment lee
l'idée ce qu'il faut vraiment retenir
ici c'est qu'on est sûr de la
productivité productivité familiale un
ordinateur qui servira à plein de choses
pour venir faire du traitement de texte
à la maison pour suivre de la
comptabilité pour regarder du netflix si
vous souhaitez bonjour vous êtes
vraiment limité parce que vous avez un
écran avec un taux de rafraîchissement
de 60 hertz il 14 pouces parijs voulu
faire du montage vidéo c'est pas
forcément cette machine qu'il vous faut
si vous voulez aller très loin sur du
photoshop de l'illustrateur ou que sais
je encore c'est pas nécessairement là
dessus qu'il faudra aller mais pour
avoir un ordi pour la maison avec de la
polyvalence facile emmener partout avec
soi c'est une machine qu'est super
intéressante on un verre corning gorilla
4 long calvaire qui est traité
anti-bactérien en plus de l'écran ce que
je viens apprécié c'est le clavier qui
même si les compas très très agréable on
trouve les touches assez facilement
alors il faut le temps de s'y faire pour
venir trouver c'est la position de ses
mains c'est assez intuitif
une fois que vous l'avez pris en main
voulait propre cas sous vos doigts
j'aime bien aussi trackpad qui bien que
le format soit compact et bien on arrive
à utiliser facilement et on prend très
facilement ses repères ça fonctionne
très très bien j'aime bien aussi le côté
sécurité grâce à windows lots de pouvoir
déverrouiller facilement grâce à votre
capteur d'empreintes digitales
ça c'est aussi pratique vous avez votre
webcam qui est idéalement placé alors
c'est du 720p donc on va pas les
extrêmement loin mais pour venir faire
un peu de vision est aujourd'hui à
vision c'est vraiment le truc qui
cartonne à cause de cette pandémie donc
on doit faire un peu de visio ça
fonctionnera sans aucun problème j'aime
bien l'idée de ce solde or ball 4 qui
vous permet de venir brancher un disque
dur externe
la connectique elle n'est pas énorme de
notre côté on n'a pas beaucoup beaucoup
de place et malgré tout et malgré tout
le fait qu'on ait l'âge des amis 2.0
ça fonctionne bien le symbole 400 va
très bien les deux prix
usbco 3.2 samba aussi parfaitement bien
en plus il est super intéressante grâce
au wifi 6 donc vous allez aller plus
vite en termes de connexion côté
performances on se le dire il faut être
extrêmement clair c'est pas là dessus
qu'on va voir une machine qui va être
une bête de combat que le processeur
fonctionnera bien on est sur un intel
core 2 11e génération vous partez dans
l'île sainte pour aller jusqu'à 17 mai
pour vous parler de performance je vais
donner la parole à mon pote arnaud de la
chaîne arnaud c'est que je vous invite à
venir découvrir tout médaille en le lien
de sa chaîne en bas dans la description
qu'on vient voir il a fait une vidéo de
test complète avec des benchmark de ce
swift de 5-plus donc lui donner la
parole pour venir vous dire ce qu'il en
pense lui en termes de performances on
va les regarder un petit peu la
configuration interne de cet ordinateur
il est équipé d'un intel core i7 11e et
génération le 11 65 g7 donc là on est
sur un processeur clic à danser avec
quatre coeurs à 2,8 gigahertz et sur un
seul coeur qui peut monter jusqu'à un
boost de 88 7 jrs un d'ailleurs lake
isle p3 processeur quadricore afin
puissance basé sur le tiger lake pour
les ordinateurs portables minces et
légers dont on est vraiment sur ce qui
est intéressant sur pc c'est à dire que
on est sur un quatre coeurs qui tourne
autour donc vous jeudi de 0,8 et jusqu'à
4,7 gigahertz
donc on a de la puissance interne cet
ordinateur et le gros avantage de ce
processeur c'est qu'il est très bon mais
l'un très bon comportement sur photoshop
et tout ce qui est traitement qui vont
solliciter processeur fortement ce
processeur un très bon rapport et une
consommation très intéressante
par contre ce qui est très intéressant
sur ce pc comme on peut le voir c'est
que vous allez le voir la carte
graphique est pas ouf
par contre le processeur lui fait
largement le nouveau sur photoshop et et
surtout ce qui va demander un petit peu
puissance nouveaux processeurs spéciaux
avons très bien débrouillé dans un très
bon comportement
on ira au processeur graphique on est
sûr l'intel iris 10e graphique j'ai
cette 93e us donc on est sur un
processeur graphique qui est intégrée au
processeur on sait s'est pas loupé mais
c'est pas ce qu'on lui demande à cet
ordinateur on lui demande de l'autonomie
pour de la bureautique
en plus de ça et rajouter 16 giga de ram
qui l'a par contre sont soudas la carte
mère vous pourrez pas les démonter pour
tenir l'échangé pour augmenter mais sur
16 giga de ram
on est quand même très bien
y a rien à dire là-dessus et occupé de
stockage d'un terreau a opté en ssd m2
qui permet dans la vitesse d'exécution
démarrage extinction lancement des
logiciels c'est quand même très
intéressant merci arnaud aller jeter un
coup d'oeil à sa chaîne arnaud est un
spécialiste du pc pc gaming pc en tout
genre il vous fait des benchmarks il
vous en parle il met tout ça en avant il
voulait qu'on part enfin bref ça c'est
intéressant je vous mets le lien une
fois de plus de sa chaîne en bas dans la
description il se retrouve une batterie
de 56 water acer nous annonce jusqu'à 17
heures 17 heures d'autonomie alors les
17 heures si vous voulez trouver tant
mieux bravo à vous on va pas arriver
jusqu'à 17h mais malgré tout et ça c'est
super intéressant
l'autonomie elle est vraiment là et ça
des très gros point fort de cet
ultraportable extrêmement compact et qui
va très loin
15h vous les avez sans aucun problème
comme on est passé sur une machine qui
va être là pour le gaming ont pas
vraiment le faire turbiner à fond vous
êtes sur la productivité vous allez
garder vos quinze ans vous allez avoir
vos 15 heures a bien évidemment fluctuer
en fonction de ce que vous allez lui
demander mais les 15 heures globalement
vous pouvez les avoir acheté sa super
intéressant c'est vraiment des très très
gros point fort parce que ce qui nous
intéresse avec un ordinateur comme ça
c'est que quand vous êtes en déplacement
alors un petit peu moins aujourd'hui les
déplacements mais vous ne voulez pas
toujours le brancher sur le secteur
et bien vous pouvez le garder un long
moment sans aucun problème et ça c'est
bien est ce que j'aime bien en plus
c'est le système de ventilation le fait
que savait le soulever légèrement pour
permettre une meilleure dissipation
thermique c'est intéressant on a une
recharge qui est suffisamment rapide en
30 minutes de charge volume était 4
heures d'autonomie
après on est sur un pc windows 10 on
connaît ça fonctionne bien il ya cortana
si vous avez besoin et côté tarifs en
aussi à 1000 euros à quelque chose près
1099 jusqu à 2499 si vous pouvez aller
sur un intel core i7 ça sera mieux c'est
pour avoir un stockage un poil plus
grands il ya un peu plus de real c'est
ce qui conviendra le mieux
ce que je trouve intéressant ici c'est
que c'est l'ordinateur convard mais
partout tout le temps avec soi
extrêmement facilement et il va répondre
à trois quarts des usages courants qu'on
peut avoir sur un ordinateur sur un côté
de productivité familiale ou
productivité professionnelle un peu de
divertissement du traitement texte
rester en lien les conférences à
distance on est vraiment dans cet usage
l'a donc pour ça j'aime bien ce que
j'aime un tout petit peu moins c'est
j'ai pas garde les finitions mais le
fait d'avoir des matériaux extrêmement
souple sur le dessus où on se sent ça
vient bush
lorsque vous appuyez au niveau de votre
clavier ça vient petit peu bougé
j'aurais aimé quelque chose qui me
paraissent un poil plus robuste
je dis pas que l'ordinateur n'est pas
robuste qu'il est fragile je dis pas ça
on voit que ces finitions vont dans le
sens de gagner du poids
clairement le petit bémol chevaux est
donné c'est que quand ils montent à
pleine puissance en fait ben
effectivement il a tendance à chauffer
pas mal donc l'ordinateur lui-même va
descendre on va dire les performances du
processeur de la ram tout ça pour
arriver à descendre la température du
coup vous être un petit peu [ __ ] mais
c'est normal c'est un ultrabook faut pas
l'oublier autre chose un peu moyenne
dessus encore c'est du détail
la carte graphique qui n'est pas dédié
mais encore une fois c'est pas l'utilité
commune monde et en plus de ça pour
terminer son prix qui est un petit peu
cher pour l'ultrabook
oui et non parce qu'il propose c'est une
des belles choses dans lesquelles son
ultrabook qui avoisine et 1500 par
contre malgré tout se défend très bien
parce qu'effectivement ces ordinateurs
monte pas à pleine puissance
systématiquement mais malgré tout le
fait de réduire un petit peu les
caractéristiques et la puissance du
matériel à l'intérieur les ordinateurs
et très silencieux
du coup vous passer assez on va dire
incognito là où vous êtes avec votre
ordi on évite les brosses soufflerie qui
font beaucoup de bruit vingt sept ont
redit
donc ça c'est quand même pas mal en plus
de ça un core i7 donc en tailleur lake
uhp 3 qui lui a permis d'être une
consommation réduite de l'ordinateur on
est encore une fois bien en plus de sa
soeur kim puissant allah a vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez vous en bas
en commentaire comment vous le trouvez
cet acer swift 5 de 2021 je vous ai déjà
parlé d'autres pc de la star dites moi
ce que vous en pensez marqué le mois en
bas en commentaire est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu un script de 5,2 à celle est-ce
que vous avez un autre ultraportable est
est ce que cet ultraportable pourrait
vous intéresser aujourd'hui en 2021 et
est ce que ça vous botte dernière
question est ce que ça vous botte qu'on
parle d'eux portable plus ou pas vous
avez donc à lire tout ça on va en
commentaire et dévia mans vous invite à
les jeter un coup d'oeil à la chaîne de
maupas tarnos et qui vous parle
d'ordinateurs de portables dutra
portable 2 pc de gaming tout dans
l'univers du portable
le lien est en bas dans la description
des lobbies ou prenez soin de vous des
coeurs et à très bientôt
ciao